At this point in the course
you've learned about a few
different techniques for
handling images on the web.
For instance,
you can use external files and
just link to them in your html or
you can inline images and
put all the data you need for
an image right there on your page.
You can use Raster images like this
picture of the star called Electra.
Or you can use Vector images like this
star from the Material Design icon set.
And then of course you can issue images
altogether and use font icons like font
awesome and then use CSS techniques for
styling them.
Funny thing is that any and
all of these techniques can lead to
pretty much the same result on the page.
The so called, right strategy.
Notice the air quotes there,
for including an image,
almost completely depends on the images
place in your app, as a whole.
For the next few quizzes, I want you to
think through some of the scenarios, and
decide the best course of action.
Here's the first scenario.
You're developing a mobile app that
displays an ever changing catalog
of bikes for sale.
You need an image for
this start right here,
to indicate which bikes have just gone
on sale within the last 24 hours.
You want to scale the star
image with the rest of the app,
in order to fit mobile phones and
tablet's proportionally.
So should you use a vector graphic or
a raster graphic and
should you inline the icon or should
you set its source to external file.
Think it through and pick the best
answer for both the questions.